hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcasts clinical whole genome
sequencing in a healthy population
I'm Christina Joel of lab works and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational seminars presented
by lab rates the leading scientific
social networking website and provider
of virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
for more information go to WWE on we
have a few important announcements
before we begin this webcast is designed
to be interactive and we encourage you
to ask questions during the event you
can submit questions by typing them in
the Q&A box which can be found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
we'll try to answer as many questions as
we can you can enlarge the slide window
by clicking on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you have any technical
problems viewing or hearing this
presentation please click on the support
button at the top of right of your
presentation window or submit your
problem through the green Q&A button on
the lower left I would now like to
introduce today's speaker
Erica Ramos Erica Ramos MSL CGC is the
clinical head for a luminous healthy
genome initiatives team and
president-elect for the National Society
of genetic counselors the leading
professional organization for genetic
counselors more than 3,500 members
strong after 11 years in patient care
miss Ramos joined Illumina in the
clinical services laboratory where she
managed the clinical group that
implemented interpretation and reporting
processes for clinical whole genome
sequencing see WGS currently she focuses
on advancing the use of CW GS by
providing access and education to
healthy individuals through the
understanding understand her genome
program my genome visualization software
and other collaborations her focus on
education extends to genetic counseling
students and she is adjunct professor in
the genetic counseling department at
Alba SCANA University she also tweets
from at a wellness SD about genomics and
genetic counseling music travel and
other interests I will now turn the
presentation over to Miss Erica R almost
Thank You Christine it's really a
pleasure to talk to everyone about this
topic today I have a clinical genetic
counselor my whole world and genetic
counseling really started when genetics
was mostly being used to affect people
who were already ill and one of the
really exciting things that we have the
opportunity to do now is actually to
start taking care of people when they're
healthy and start predicting what
diseases they may be at risk for and
we've started this program through our
company Illumina called understand your
genome and we've now sequence through
this over 1,300 people so we have a lot
of really great information about what
this means in a healthy population and
that's what I'd like to share with you
all today as I mentioned when we think
about clinical genetics and genetic
counseling usually we think about kids
like this and this is really how
genetics and genomics got started and
still today as its most common use this
was actually the first story of a child
who was helped by something we call
whole exome sequencing which is a
technique that looks at just the coding
region regions of a particular genome
this little boy his name is Nick Mulder
and he was as you can probably tell a
very very sick little boy this picture
was taken when he was about 5 years old
he had an extremely severe form of
inflammatory bowel disease in just two
years more than a hundred trips to the
operating room and had spent more than
300 days in the hospital by the time he
was five years old in 2009 one of them
were critical things about this story
particularly from our healthcare
perspective is that by the time he was
just 5 they had spent more than 2
million dollars on his healthcare and
we're getting nowhere he was gonna die
there was no question and his physician
had called up a really phenomenal
geneticist named Howard Jacob at the
Medical College of Wisconsin and said I
keep hearing about all this whole genome
sequencing stuff is there any way that
this technology can help Nick because
his doctor knew this had to be something
June
it was such a rare form of inflammatory
bowel disease it was so severe and to
see it in such a young child just didn't
make sense
fortunately for Nick Howard took on the
challenge and along with his team they
sequence Nick's exome and they were
actually the first group to do whole
exome sequencing at the time the cost
was over seventy thousand dollars just
to look at Nick's exome and that's only
about one did she percent on his entire
genome this is all the coding regions of
the genome when they looked at Nick's
exome they had over 16,000 candidates
for the genetic variant that might be
causing his disease and his team
actually had to build tools so that they
could analyze this data they did such a
great job that they were able to narrow
it down to one and that one very
specific change is a change in a gene
called X ia P this particular genetic
change was just one letter engine mixed
genome but this particular genetic
change had never been seen in anybody
but Nick and Nick's mom this happens to
be on the X chromosome so it's an
excellent genetic disorder and even
still to this day to the best of my
knowledge Nick and his mom are the only
people that we've ever identified that
had this particular genetic change so
this was Nick NAT this was Nick Ben and
this is Nick now Nick's life was saved
by whole exome sequencing and Howard's
team when they diagnosed this particular
mutation and the xip gene they diagnosed
Nick with a disease that was actually
treatable with a bone-marrow transplant
and after a bone marrow transplant and
along uphill battle to recover Nick is
now nine years old and doing really
really well
this was actually Nick at the opening of
the Hudson alpha Smith's genomic
medicine Center which is where Howard
Jacob and his team are now and if you're
interested in more on Nick's story which
I guarantee is worth the read they that
there were two Journal article or two
journalists that published a Pulitzer
Prize winning story about Nick in the
Milwaukee Journal Sentinel and it's now
a book
really really phenomenal read for
anybody who's interested and how
genomics started so the other thing that
you may have noticed is that this was us
just you know six years ago or so we
haven't it's been a long uphill climb
but we've made an incredible amount of
progress in that time and now whole
exome sequencing that Nick has is
something that's offered fairly standard
a fairly standard lead to a lot of kids
with undiagnosable genetic diseases so
the next step is how do we use this in
healthy people this is just a map
showing are what we call understand your
genome program and we started this
program in 2012 since that time as I
mentioned we sequenced more than 1300
healthy individuals I bring this up to
show you that we've sequenced people all
over the world of different races
ethnicities although it's also a leader
there's still a pretty consistent trend
in the people that we've sequenced and
up until now this is actually the
largest cohort of individuals that we're
aware of that have had whole genome
sequencing done in a clinical laboratory
setting with return of results it's a
particular test that they have is
something we call our predisposition
screen and it looks at more than 1,600
different genes for about 1,200
different disorders and a
pharmacogenomics panel so that gives you
an idea of the scope of the types of
things that we've been looking for in
this population now obviously that's not
us doing interpretation on a whole
genome and we still have a lot of a long
way to go before we're able to really
really get all of the information that
we want out of the genome but we have
learned a lot of lessons from sequencing
1,300 healthy people and those are some
of the things that I want to share with
you today along with some of the other
advances that are happening in fortune
or sequencing so one of the key messages
that I learned and I was honestly a
little bit surprised by was that
sequencing healthy people is
accelerating discovery in multiple
multiple areas including in rare disease
as I mentioned with Nick what we're
really doing with
Disease analysis is to try to find the
one or two variations in the genome that
are causing an individual's disease now
we have more than three three billion
base pairs in our genome so we're
looking for one to two of those that are
actually causing problems and that's
essentially the quintessential needle in
a haystack problem
so the more information we have about
what's normal in a genome
the more the benefits are to finding
those conditions in a rare disease
population the more it helps us rule
things out faster if a genetic variant
is actually very prevalent in the
general population it's much easier for
scientists to say nope this is not
what's causing that very very rare
disorder so the more information we
gather about what's normal in a genome
the better job we can do in analyzing
rare disease cases like what we did with
Nick the other really interesting area
that we're moving into is looking at
people who actually have genetic
variants that should have genetic
disease this picture is from a really
fantastic article by Ed Young that was
in the Atlantic last year and they were
this is about a study called the
resilience project out of Mount Sinai
and this particular project was looking
specifically for people who seem to have
genetic mutations that should cause
disease so one really common example of
that is in the cystic fibrosis gene CFTR
the most common known pathogenic
mutation in that particular gene is the
Delta F 508 mutation and if you two
copies of Delta F 508 traditional
medicine and traditional genetics would
say you absolutely have should have
cystic fibrosis this study actually
found somebody who had those two copies
but didn't seem to have the disease and
they found several other people that
seemed to have these issues so what does
that tell us well first of all it's
telling us that we actually have a
little bit of selection bias when we've
done genetic testing and when you think
of the cost of genetic testing and how
it was implemented we didn't go out and
test
in the world for cystic fibrosis we only
tested the people who showed symptoms
and we tested their family members so
now that we have the ability to go out
and test a lot of people what we're
learning is that maybe the spectrum of
cystic fibrosis is much broader than we
thought it was before additionally these
individuals might have things in their
genome that are actually keeping them
from getting cystic fibrosis so these
would be protecting variants that
actually could be treatment targets and
actually benefit people with cystic
fibrosis or with other diseases another
very very common genetic disorder is
sickle cell disease so sickle cell
disease occurs in about one in 400
African Americans and about one in ten
African Americans are carriers for that
particular condition recently there are
some studies that looked and again saw
people that had these two sickle-cell
mutations and should have the disease
and what they found was they actually
had a third mutation that affected the
production of fetal hemoglobin and
because of that third mutation they
never went on to develop full-blown
sickle cell disease
now that mutation is now a target and
something that researchers are looking
at to see if they can treat sickle cell
disease in that way instead of the way
that we traditionally been treating it
so this is great we're gonna sequence
all these healthy people and get try to
get answers for rare disease and even
some common rare diseases but how does
that benefit that healthy well this is
really a cyclical relationship if we
sequence a lot of people and we learn
what mutations might be beneficial and
what might help to prevent those
individuals from getting the genetic
diseases that we thought we knew really
well we can also take genetic diseases
that are rare and look at how they might
tie to the healthy so this is one
example if you look at the x-ray of the
individual on the left it's from an
individual that has a disease called
osteoporosis so an over density of bone
on the right is something that we're
more familiar with which is osteoporosis
which is an which is a lack of density
in the bone now you can imagine that if
there's a genetic change
that helps to make bones more dense than
they should be you could probably start
taking information about that gene or
that genetic change and start to create
therapies for us to be a process based
on that information so it really works
in both directions the more we learn
about rare disease by testing the
healthy the more we benefit both the
more we learn about where our healthy
people we benefit the rare now how do we
do this well one example is by donating
our genetic information and there's a
really fantastic resource that was
created over the last several years
called clinvar and this is currently the
largest repository of genetic variants
that also has information about whether
a clinical lab thinks that variant is
related to disease so when we call a
variant pathogenic for instance we're
saying that we have good confidence that
that's related to a disease and clinvar
is one of the first that's actually tied
the variant information to these
interpretations of pathogenic benign etc
through our 1,300 people that we've
tested in the uig program our lab is
actually donated more than 95,000
variants to clinvar which is pretty huge
so in 99 percent of those that the lab
has donated came from our uig
participants now as I mentioned this
databases is from all clinical labs so a
lot of the information in that database
comes from sick people and now this is a
contribution that helps us to balance
out the sick and the healthy what they
have right now is or the more than
200,000 variants that have evidence and
when we say that something has evidence
we mean that it has the information that
the lab used to call it pathogenic or in
variant of unknown significance or
benign our particular donation added
more than 50,000 variants to that
database
so again sequencing even 1,300 healthy
people is adding huge amounts of data to
these really critical databases that
help to diagnose
that kids and help to do helped labs to
do a better job at what they do but the
really powerful thing starts to come
when we look even bigger so there's a
really phenomenal researcher and at the
braid Institute in Boston named Ann
McArthur and again a great article by
and young in the Atlantic that and one
of the comments that Dan made in this
article about building these big
libraries of genetic information is that
in an ideal world you would compare all
of a patient's variants against every
individual who's ever been sequenced in
the history of sequencing now if you
remember back to my needle in the
haystack slide that starts to make sense
right so we need to figure out if that
one or two variants that our sick person
has are different than what we see in
the general population so ideally you
want to look at everybody else and see
if they also have those genetic changes
the assumption being that if healthy
people have them it's probably not
what's causing a very rare disease but
how many people does Dan mean when he
says everybody and he's ever been
sequenced in the history of sequencing
well so far that's not probably as high
as we'd like and if you they just about
three months ago and Dan's lab came out
with a addition to their existing
browser called exact and the new one is
called nomad and these particular
databases have about a hundred and
twenty six thousand exomes so again
that's the coding regions of the genome
about one to two percent of the genome
and about 15,000 whole genome sequences
so right now this is the biggest public
database that's available to look to see
what's in a particular genome and the
huge advantage here and what we really
get from Dan's types of databases is
something that we call allele
frequencies so what this tells us is how
common is a particular variant in a
particular population and that frequency
of an allele is really critical to labs
when they're trying to make assessments
about whether something is related to
disease or not
so you can imagine when these two
databases are there when you have this
huge database that says how common a
variant is in multiple different
populations and then you have a database
that helps to tell you what other labs
have seen especially for these more rare
variants we're really creating a
resource that every clinical lab out
there can use to help to do a better job
of interpreting genetic variation so why
is this important well part of the
limitations and one of the things that
people will push back on when we talk
about sequencing a lot of people or
sequencing healthy people is that
there's a lot of uncertainty in the
genome and that's 100% true but there's
really two things that I think are
important to highlight around the
uncertainty in the genome the first is
that this is absolutely not unique to
genetics and this happens all the time
and the example we use a lot is in
radiology and so as we develop new
technology new things you learn new
things so this is actually an image from
brain MRI and this is something called
diffusion tensor imaging
which checks the non-random movement of
water molecules through the brain this
is considered a typical DTI image of the
brain and about 10 years ago now I had
an MRI and this is what my DTI looked
like now you guys don't know this but
generally I'm a pretty highly functional
adult and this was a big surprise to the
gym to the radiologists that had scanned
me and the reality is that if he didn't
know who I was and that I didn't have
any major brain injuries or anything
like that this would have been really
really concerning to him so number one
lesson is that we have to take it all
uncertainty in genetics and compare it
to the uncertainty that we've used how
we probably resolved uncertainty in
other fields in this particular case and
what we always encourage in genetics is
really to merge the genetic information
or the technical information with the
clinical so in this case
radiologists talked to me and said hey
something looks a little funny on your
imaging tell me about your history and I
told him that when I was younger I had a
concussion and from his perspective that
fully explained this particular finding
we have to do the same thing with
genetics we can't just look at it in a
bubble we have to tie it to cheapest
clinical findings and to other tests but
the other thing to know is that we will
get over that so the more people we test
the more information we have and the
better job were able to do with that um
one of the big historical concerns that
goes along with this is that patients
are not going to be able to deal with
this level of uncertainty and again what
I can tell you from my personal
experiences that we're much less
probable it's much less problematic for
us as patients than it is for us as
clinicians as a genetic counselor I
would absolutely worry about my patients
ability to understand what we call a
variants of uncertain significance
seeing something in their genetic makeup
that we just don't know what to do it
but in radiology and as a patient I was
perfectly comfortable that I'm a healthy
individual this clearly isn't doing
anything to me so far so it's probably
okay now this is going to become
important as we start launching some of
these big precision medicine initiatives
that you probably have been hearing
about and will continue to hear about
and a bit over a year ago President
Obama announced what we called the
precision medicine initiative or now
something that's referred to as all of
us and the reason this is so critical is
that this particular program is really
meant to build the largest database in
the United States of personal
information of the of our participants
that contributes to personalized
medicine so that's not just going to be
genetics that's going to be people's
fitbit's that's going to be their
medical records that's going to be a lot
of information about their health so
that that data can be mined by
researchers and can be used to advance
the concepts of personalized or
precision medicine
some of the things that I just mentioned
Fitbit data healthcare records genetic
data we think of that as pretty
sensitive stuff and we were really
curious from our perspective on how
likely a broad population was to accept
that so here in San Diego we partnered
with what's called the San Diego blood
bank to work on a project and a
community genomics initiative that
really brought together the altruism of
a blood bank population with the
innovation of genetic technology and so
some of you may know our San Diego
Chargers seem to have migrated a bit up
north now but historically the Chargers
have had an annual blood drive every
year right before Thanksgiving and it's
the biggest blood drive one of the
biggest blood drives in the world it's
actually one McGuiness world record for
largest blood drive or more at most
blood donated and this has really been
an institution in San Diego so we
thought it would be great to partner
genomics education at this event with
the test that actually looked at 70
blood donors to see if we could get
blood donors to contribute genetic data
what type of data they might be
interested in contributing and really if
we could even use blood centers as a
good merchant the reason this is
important is that our typical
participant in whole genome sequencing
or genomic studies right now tends to
fall into a very narrow category they
are mostly male they are mostly
Caucasian they are mostly well-educated
they're mostly wealthy and this is data
that's based on a program that are
understanding your genome participants
participate in call people seek that's
run out of dr. Robert greens greens
group at Harvard and this particular
study is looking at lots of different
initiatives that have done personal
genome sequencing like uig and this is
sort of what they're finding so this was
not all of their participants but we see
this trend pretty typically across other
studies as well so the issue here is
that the more diversity we have in
genomics the better job we're going to
do improving personalized and precision
medicine
everybody and part of the precision
medicine initiative part of their charge
is actually to get a representative
sampling of the population of the United
States and we know that this is not what
the United States looks like we need to
do a much better job of recruiting
people of different ethnicities
different education levels in order to
really hit that goal so that's what we
focused on as part of this pilot project
that we did in collaboration with the
San Diego blood bank
this particular graph and I have many
more on a lot of other characteristics
this happens to focus on race what we
did was we took the San Diego census and
we sent out invitations to a huge group
of blood donors and got more than 7,000
responses from people who were
interested in participating in this type
of study so a really really phenomenal
response rate from a very engaged
altruistic population which wasn't
surprising to us but it was what we were
hoping for um what you can see here is
that we actually do have a really great
representation of race we did the same
for education level we did the same for
income we split it up by gender by age
so we were able to really select a very
representative sampling of San Diego and
if anything we were able to over select
for populations that are typically under
represented so more women more
ethnicities that in races that turn to
be underrepresented so what did we find
we found that our concern of whether
they would provide this information or
not was fortunately probably not an
issue what they were more than more than
60 percent of people were willing to
provide information from their fit bed
information about their lifestyle
biological samples genetic data and they
were willing to connect to contribute
survey data the only things that were a
little bit lower than that was
information from their health record
which is kind of understandable there's
obviously a lot of concern about sharing
that information and information from
their social media accounts which we all
thought
sort of interesting considering how much
people put out on social media so what
we were able to show was that when we
start looking at how we can engage with
a healthy population number one is that
partnering with great organizations that
are trusted in a community is very
valuable but overall people of all
different races ages economic
backgrounds are really willing to
participate they understand genomics is
important and they want to contribute so
if we can reach them in the right ways
we have a really good shot of getting a
very successful and diverse study in the
PMI so what are some of the other things
that we learned one of our biggest
lessons and this is something that I
think is the most critical as we move
forward in implementing this in
healthcare is that we actually find a
lot in a genome that we presume to be
healthy there's a lot of people who now
will not say there's a healthy genome
and I think I would probably agree with
that because we know that all of us have
things in our family we have certain
risks for diseases and there's a lot of
different places that this can actually
be beneficial before someone gets sick
or before they start to take a
medication so this is a graph of a group
of uig participants that came from the
Mayo Clinic in Florida and what you can
see across the bottom are the numbers of
our individual participants so 1 through
39 and each of these colored bars
actually represents from one common drug
where that particular individual had a
different than typical metabolism for
that medication so the in this first
column you can see four colored blocks
that particular individual had a
different than typical metabolism for
the loop integral also known as cravaack
and for tricyclic antidepressants and
for two places that two things that
impact warfarin there's howell ism now
this is my pharmacogenetics is kind of
considered the low line these are very
very common drugs that are prescribed
now that doesn't mean that these people
were taking these medications but we
know that there are some
they plant that they may plan to take
out some time in the future and
certainly with warfarin what often
happens is they don't know they're going
to take that information what will come
is that somebody will get a blood clot
and the first medication that they are
typically given to treat that blood clot
is warfarin now we also have the ability
with the genome to help to start
figuring out who's higher risk for those
blood clots and so that was the second
thing that we looked at with these
particular individuals these purple
stars at the top of bar 5 and bar 27
those purple stars indicate people who
have a mutation called factor v leiden
and the factor 5 Leiden mutation is
something that can increase the chance
that somebody will develop a blood clot
in their lifetime it's not a huge
increase but it is somewhat significant
particularly when it's in combination
with other risk factors like birth
control pills are smoking so not only
are these two individuals people who are
more likely to get blood clots than
somebody in the general population but
they're also the people who have
different than typical metabolisms from
warfarin so these are people who would
benefit from the potentially a different
don't starting dose of warfarin to have
a lower rate of complications or in
efficacious dosing so this is one of the
big advantages of whole genome
sequencing or testing genomics and a
healthy person it's not just getting the
pharmacogenomics data it's being able to
look at other risk factors and tying
those two pieces together now it's not
just about those things and certainly
not everybody will have a response for
some of these different things but
sometimes there's actually even more
significant things that come up so in
our San Diego blood bank study one of
the really neat things that we were able
to do is to partner with a group called
inform DNA to offer a genetic counseling
and return of results to each of our
participants so we collected a really
detailed family history and we were also
able to talk a lot to them about their
results and get feedback about what
their experience was
and what they plan to do moving forward
this particular case was a young male
and when he first consented to the study
he hadn't talked about any specific
family history and he didn't report
anything's too significant she the
genetic counselor after his results were
available and when he was asked why he
decided to participate he said that the
San Diego blood bank hassles them pretty
regularly about his blood type so he
thought why not now that's obviously not
the reason that most people decide to
pursue genetic testing it doesn't tend
to be a just because I wanted she would
just because sort of thing so this is
kind of interesting because he really
wasn't expecting to find much and he
really wasn't going into the test trying
to gather information so what did we
find one of the things that we found was
a likely pathogenic variant in a gene
that we know can increase risk for
cardiomyopathy this particular gene
impacts risk for ARV C which is the
genic right ventricular cardiomyopathy
for those who may not be as familiar
this particular form of cardiomyopathy
can be related to sudden death and so
it's really important for us to be aware
of these types of risks before an
individual has a cardiac event
the other thing we found was that he's a
carrier for that common cystic fibrosis
variant but I mentioned before Delta at
5:08 so when we looked at his family
tree
he's the square down there the 26 year
old with the arrow pointing to him and
it was sort of interesting because a RVC
is actually what we call a dominant
genetic disease and that means that
oftentimes there's a family history when
we looked at his family though it
actually makes sense if you see the
brackets around his mother
so the 49 year old that means that she
was adopted so he actually did not have
any information about his mother's side
of the family and we also know that
cardiomyopathy is not fully punishment
so it is possible to have a genetic
variant that could cause the disease but
not ever develop it and if that risk for
developing disease
does go up with age so his mom's still
fairly young it may be that over time
she would have a risk to develop that
particular disease but hasn't yet so
well what did we learn from this just
this one genome sequence we've learned
that this particular individual has this
risk for cardiomyopathy himself and most
likely he inherited that from his mother
although she would need to be tested to
confirm that so if we confirm that we've
essentially been able to identify two
people that certain almost certainly
have an increased risk of cardio Mile
cardiomyopathy and as a result of sudden
cardiac death we also know that his
brother has a 50% chance of inheriting
that cardiomyopathy variance so he also
needs to be tested and we could then
identify up to three people in this
family that have that significant risk
his brother also has a 50% chance of
carrying not cystic fibrosis variant so
where that plays in is if they decide to
have children and their children also
have a chance to inherit both of those
variants and if either of them have a
child with a woman who's a carrier for
cystic fibrosis though they're children
not only could be at risk for cardiology
but also for cystic fibrosis so how is
he feeling and what is he gonna do next
um he certainly did say that the ARV C
was unexpected but when he had
originally had the consenting session
the genetic counselor who consented him
had talked to him about the fact that he
was his mother was adopted and that when
we do find surprises in the family
history or surprises in the genomic
information that are pretty big things
it tends to be because we don't know
part of the family history so that big
consenting process and really making
sure that he knew what to expect in
advance was really valuable to him and
since he had time to think about it and
know that there was something that might
come up because of his mother's unknown
family history he was doing okay with
this information he said he's going to
get a cardiologist and
did say that he would talk to his family
and he did understand that both his
mother and his brother were potentially
at risk to have this thing genetic
variant so this is really one of the
things that we recognized and of course
this is just one example and what I can
tell you though is this is not atypical
for understand your genome participants
in our 70 San Diego blood bank
participants we actually had another
gentleman who we diagnosed as having a
hereditary form of arrhythmia and not
only did he report a history of
arrhythmia but he reported that his
granddaughter a young girl in her teens
was actually recently put on exercise
restrictions and had some sort of heart
thing so you know 70 people that we
tested completely randomly from the
population in San Diego two of those 70
people had pretty important findings
that impacted not only them but their
family members and that's just one set
of examples the two genes that I
mentioned that related to the
cardiomyopathy and the arrhythmia a part
of a set of genes that we call the ACMG
56
so a few years ago the American College
of medical genetics and genomics came
out with a list of 56 genes and what
they said was that if you're going to do
whole genome or whole exome sequencing
for any reason where disease or for
healthy people you should always look
for these 56 genes and that's because
these are what we call highly actionable
genes so these are genes like brca1 and
2 that predispose for hereditary breast
and ovarian cancer the genes related to
Lynch syndrome which is a hereditary
form of colon under neutral ovarian and
other cancers and cardiomyopathies and
hereditary arrhythmias along with some
other disorders we didn't know how
common these things were going to be
when we look at them historically and
what we see in the population they don't
seem that common by themselves but what
we actually found in our lab was that
about 2 and 1/2 percent of our healthy
people
actually had known pathogenic mutations
in one of these 56 genes these are
almost all what we call dominant
diseases again genes that if you have
even one pathogenic variant you might
develop the disease and you're a
first-degree relatives so parents
siblings children also have a 50% chance
to develop those same conditions so
these are really really high impact
variants for us to find and we're
actually finding them in about one in 40
people in the general population so as
the genetic counseling that was actually
really shocking to me and it's not just
in our lab that we're finding this this
is really pretty consistent that work
that other groups are finding as well so
what is all this lead us to I think the
really exciting thing about what might
come next is that the more data we
collect in a healthy population the more
we have the ability to inform things
around population screening so back in
2014 dr. Mary Claire King who is
incredibly well known for being one of
the discoverers of the brca1 and brca2
hereditary cancer genes dr. King was
awarded the Lasker Award and as part of
the Lasker Award she published this
particular paper and really made the
case for screening everybody for brca1
and brca2 now historically we've had
very specific groups of people that we
offer this genetic testing to and a lot
of that rationale was number one it's
not likely to find a mutation if you
don't fit into one of these predefined
categories and number two if you don't
fit into one of those previously defined
pre previously defined categories the
odds of finding one of those uncertain
results exceeds the odds of finding
something significant what she says in
this paper though is that in the United
States the number of brca1 and brca2
carriers is about one in three
- one in 500 people now this particular
case she focused on women because
they're the highest risk of developing
the cancers related to these genes so
that means that in the u.s. there are
somewhere between two hundred and fifty
thousand to four hundred and fifteen
thousand adult women that have brca1 or
2 mutations and 14 breast and ovarian
cancer is both highly likely and
potentially preventable so that's a
pretty big number and what dr. King had
was able to demonstrate was that even
when we did this testing in an
unselected population these individuals
so no known family history no personal
history these women were still very high
risk for breast cancer
there were a lot a couple different
groups so HudsonAlpha
where dr. jacob is one and a lab called
council in san francisco was another
that sort of took her challenge on and
said we're gonna offer testing for these
genes to everyone so we can learn more
about what these look like in a general
population and the really interesting
thing they found was that about 50% so
half of the people who had these
pathogenic mutations in these very very
important predatory cancer genes did not
fall into one of our previously defined
groups they didn't have the personal or
family history that genetic counselors
like me or others would have used to
identify them as high-risk and they very
likely could have developed cancer
without ever knowing they were BRCA
positive so this to me was really
impactful if we're missing 50% of these
women because of our criteria then
that's pretty strong evidence to me that
we should start thinking about testing
everybody and that's dr. Chang's
recommendation her recommendation which
she's been out talking about regularly
is that every woman age 30 and older
should be offered hereditary testing for
brca1 and brca2 and that any pathogenic
result be returned to those women so
this made me start thinking about our
ACMG 56
so there are about 238 million adults in
the u.s. one in 40 people so two and a
half percent that have those ECM g56
variants that's almost 6 million adults
in the US so that's six million of us
that are walking around with genetic
variants that could cause hereditary
cancer risk hereditary cardiac disease
risk and other genetic disease in so
that was a pretty impactful number to me
as well and I think that's one of the
things that we should be thinking about
as we start to move this forward there
is a lot of potential for benefits now
again one of the arguments that's come
up around the 56 ACMG genes is that we
don't know what the penetrance is if
there's not a family history of this
these disorders so when we talk about
penetrance again with genetic diseases
we're talking about how likely it is
that if you have a pathogenic variant
you will get the disease and the
suspicion was that potentially people
who did not have a family history would
be have a variant that has lower
penetrance than people who did have a
family history just not an unreasonable
hypothesis so fortunately dr. Robert
Greene at Harvard tested this and he
actually went back and looked at two big
studies one was the Framingham Heart
Study and one was the Jackson Heart
Study so this was about 462 European
Americans and in the Framingham study
and about 3,000 african-americans in the
Jackson Heart Study
what they did was actually do whole
exome sequencing on all of the samples
from individuals in these studies and
they have a lot of history about these
individuals and their health status so
they looked at those 56 genes without
matching them to their health status of
their clinical data and look to see how
many of those individuals had mutations
in these genes and then how many had
diseases that were tied to that so what
you can see in this particular table is
that when they looked at in the
vigils who carried variants in the ACMG
genes the number of conditions that were
related to these genes far exceeded what
they observed far exceeded what would be
expected by the population risk alone
so they took cardiovascular history into
consideration certainly because these
were those heart studies but they were
hard studies of people that were
generally healthy so when they looked
for instance at the Framingham study
they found two individuals that had
mutations in hereditary cancer genes and
both of those individuals had actually
gone on to develop cancer so what this
is telling us is even when people are
not selected because of their family
history it seems that the penetrance of
these particular genes is still fairly
strong and warrants potential testing so
as we move forward into the world of
genomic testing I think there's no
question that we're going to start
seeing this more and more in healthy
individuals fortunately we're going to
take some of the uncertainty we have now
we're going to do studies like the study
that we did with the blood bank and the
study Robert Greene is doing if people
seek and then with this data around
penetrance and we're going to learn more
so that we can apply it in the best
possible way so the message that I want
to leave you with is that this is a
process and not only that but one of the
things that we need to do is to not
think of whole genome sequencing as a
test in medicine we tend to think of
tests or most of our tests that we run
are one-time events and whole genome
sequencing is really a resource it's
something that we should be able to
continue to go back to as we learn more
as our knowledge based changes and as
new things happen for the individuals
who are sequence so that we can ask
better questions and get better answers
thank you
thank you miss Ramos for that
informative presentation now before we
get started on the question and answer
session I would like to remind our
audience how to submit questions you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to get to as many questions as we
can our first question is well what do
professional organizations say about
sequencing healthy people so currently
there are a couple different
recommendations that have come out by
societies like the National Society of
genetic counselors and the American
College of medical genomics genetics and
genomics at this point there's nothing
that says that healthy people shouldn't
consider getting in sequencing and that
really adults should decide for
themselves if getting testing is
something that they're interested in how
long on what they do recommend is that
that testing be done in the context of
genetic counseling both before the
testing and after the testing so really
having making sure those individuals are
well educated about the benefits and the
limitations of testing about any risks
that there may be for things like
insurance discrimination any concerns
that they may have about sharing that
data with family members and really if
there's anything that they may or may
not want to know so right now it's
something that isn't recommended per se
as part of normal healthcare but the
professional societies really just
suggest that if people are pursuing it
they get the right services and good
genetic counseling to go along with
next question is is this type of testing
covered by insurance so genetic testing
in general is often covered by insurance
if there's a personal or family history
of the disease that it's been that is
being looked at so for instance in cases
of whole genome sequencing or whole
exome sequencing in sick kids or sick
adults for that matter it is often
covered by insurance although the amount
of coverage may differ and that's one of
the reasons that we recommend talking to
genetic counselors to help figure out
what testing will be covered and how
much out of pocket expense patients
might have doing this type of testing
when a healthy population is not
typically covered so that's one of the
questions around the testing that
maryclaire King is promoting and one of
the concerns is that if you're a young
healthy person with no family history of
cancer your insurance isn't going to pay
for testing the advantage though is that
now that this sequencing technology is
getting less expensive and more people
are doing this type of testing and
historically there was one lab that did
BRCA testing and that testing cost about
$4,000 now there are clinical labs that
offer testing for this and other genes
at a cost of about two hundred and fifty
dollars so it's now coming to the point
where at least in some cases up hurt a
healthy person can access this type of
testing without the big out-of-pocket
expense
thank you we have time for one last
question what do you think it will be
common for everyone to get genome
sequencing as part of their health care
so I think we're still a few years off
from that and I think the estimates that
we've seen pretty frequently fall in
about the five to ten year range and
that's I don't think maybe when the
majority of people will start doing it
but certainly where it will start to be
more and more common and as importantly
we'll have doctors that are educated
about how this testing can be used will
have health care systems and technology
systems that can make it valuable and so
I think that within the next five to ten
years we'll see a lot more healthy
people with genetic information and
their records pharmacogenomic
information before they get prescribed
drugs things along those lines I'd like
to once again thank ms Erica Ramos for
her presentation ms Ramos you have any
final comments for our audience just
that I appreciate you all taking the
time to learn a little bit more about
this topic
thank you again miss Ramos I'd also like
to thank our sponsor lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
May 22nd 2017 you will receive an email
from lab roots alerting you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to forward that announcement
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event thank you for joining
us then we hope to see you next time
goodbye